just moving on with another phase of my
life getting will be getting divorced
and but it's a friendly situation where
it's supportive and loving of each other
and and sometimes things just you know
things just take a different course and
you you go let's go different direction
I'm so lucky that we're mature and adult
and you know things can be hard of
course but at the same time as we've
chosen to you know we spent 15 years
together and we should continue to be
their first core system for each other
another support system Patricia was the
cast of the series Lucifer in which she
starred as Charlotte and as Tricia told
us everything the season has been
leading up to tonight's series finale
this whole season she's been kind of
trying to find her identity having up
you know like a four-month elapsed time
of complete blackout where she was
actually down in hell and mom had you
know taken over her body
Lucifer told me everything isn't
everything as in the whole freaking
enchilada and then I was possessed by
the goddess of all creation she finally
discovers the truth you know that she
was in hell and that Lucifer is the
devil and amenadiel
is an angel I can't really give away too
much without it being a massive spoiler
but there's gonna be some it definitely
takes a dark turn